ああ
ようやくこの日が来た箱根山はじめ冊はですカルビー皆さん知ってますよねこちら
チップスとがおかしいをよく出されている会社があるんですけどそこがなんとなーんと
ですね日本て47都道府県で成り立ってるんですけども
47ふと合計すべてのポテトチップス作ったんですねこれがもーん
なんてこと知って
くっ外れるのが大変だったらそりゃもう47都道府県のコンテンツ一気にバーって出れ
ばよかったんですけどもこれが奥さんねほんとも出し方がも甘くてですね第1弾第2弾
第3弾3回受けたの都道府県を分けて打ったんで集めるのが本当に大変だった東京都心
増加の会議の高速道路のサービスエリアとまで殴ってたくさんこれ40
あと時は安倍さんと思ったんですけども部分部分しかなくて全部集めるの本当に大変
でしたいろんなとこからという世代にメルカリでしないとか買ったりで悲哀と根性で
47刀剣すべて
ほどジェクス集めさせていただきました中にはポテトだけじゃなくて
かっぱえびせんとかじゃがりことかもあるんですけども一応47点ってすべての愛表的
な味というかこの件はこんな
したうっていうのにと47種類こちらにありますそれで今日の動画もうあの
を刺しでしょ47都道府県のポテチを全て混ぜと何味になるのかやってみたいと思い
ますより
加藤なかっ
何語かわからないけどやってるじゃないですかだってこれも全部今47都道府県の私の
兄はこれはた c 道とは俺
うちはこれ前のプレやねぇ
大井戸ワールドで議論ヌー japan to do
pr
陽気ながに photoshop 一枚違いれてそれを振ればこのなに日本ができる
画期的ですよもうポテトチップスの集大成といってもおかしくありません今日で私は常
に一つをポテトチップス業界を終わらせますというわけでさっそく食べていきましょう
純風土岡山県えびめしあ二回は原はそんないったことないかもしれないなぁいただきま
んん
男性と思っています
うーんもえびめしうんまてに1枚ずつ入れていきますね
千葉県丸大豆そういう技いただきまうまいなんかめっちゃをしっかり訴訟8時ですね
おいしいおいしい東京ですかっぱえびせんテンプラー g もやっぱ浅草とかもう
the 天ぷらんでしょうねどっこ飛んで行っ
普通のカッパービスの強い側から山大変だだちゃ豆アジ
6灯具石川県
管理年8月金沢しょっぱい表現カッツ名詞であるでゴリはガッツリせてますお店
いただきますかつ
滋賀県近江牛ステーキ悪しき着想ないじゃあこれはまず前大分県か細味
on air 酸味がめちゃんこクマ長野県野沢なっちゃって
あ好きワーカーなきゃいけラーメンやつってなんかもう剣道とかちょっと
俺の好みの問題なんだろうないただけませんか
[音楽]
あー御簗行います2ゾーンとは政治て沖縄県た校内さあ g
寺海や奈良県花きの笹寿司厚
まあしびれるまたです山梨県鳥もつ煮味
ベビー福井県あぶれへしこ味なにこれあめっちゃうまえ
栃木県焼き餃子自治体に黒柴犬かつお味噌味
スモーキー島根県神出雲唐辛子安どんな全然名前だけ見ても全然はパーパ椅子いた加減
さが海苔味のりやつ
茨城が欲しいマジッああ
[音楽]
まあ秋田県きりたんぽは6 pot 熊本県下なし年高安寺
群馬県焼きまんじゅうはぜひそもそもポテチでマン殉難者菜園ぜひ宮崎県チキン南蛮寺
不明長崎県佐世保料ステーキ亜種 extra hot って牛骨ラーメン屋突く質問
はから和歌山にはちみつ&南高梅
うん
んま山賊焼きやつうまいわ
グアム前1新潟県管釣りアジ
よくわかんないさっきまた静岡県わさび漬け淳いただけました
食い過ぎでよくわかんないと他の静岡ってこんな子なんだろうな愛知店手羽先味
うんまい三重県アウターの味噌汁味魅会大阪ですねに生姜じゃあ色やば
宮城県仙台いうあぶり出しはチェック
もうあずかわかってるの京都ちりめん山椒8
岩手県盛岡ザーザー雨やスポットがわからん福島以下人時8時過ぎなぁ自骨腱ゆずぽん
酢味
埼玉県ウナギのかば焼きや車広島種なし担々麺混乱 new 県警ちゃん店は知っ
徳島県鳴門の渦潮8
北海道昆布しようず愛媛県 japan 市青森県をボリーニ cars です
香川県オリーブオイルとしは地
保護犬が号店フード味ですうんラストですはが地元富山県
白エビあちあ
ん
もう食えやばいやばいやばいはやばいやばいは47相当県次ぐ意思たら結構腹作れます
ねはいというわけで
pde
ああああ
by 時に日本の都道府県のすべてがこの中に詰まっております
見せたところで何かあるわけじゃないんですここでこのままだった47都道府県が鼻に
敷き詰められてるだけなのでこれを
まずはファー
ni
あああーー2
[音楽]
すべては
6になりましたこんなにゃん鉄がもう足かというとこれがになっちゃうんですね
で朝食47都道府県の味を味わってみましょう
[音楽]
b
ん
goo
[音楽]
ブーブー復帰
んでならいろんな地形混ざり次ってるちゃんの皆主張してくるっていうかちーて言う
なら唐揚げからやっぱりニック
芸能が多かったからそれが強くなった気がします味付けとしているから揚げみたいな
日本は唐揚げでした
[音楽]
余り過ぎたなぁ
みんなああ